BRET.
>> Bret: LIVE ON THE LINE
THERE IN MINNESOTA.
THANKS.
A LOT OF FOLKS ARE TAKING THE
INTERNET FUELED IDEA OF STORMING
AREA 51 WHERE CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS THINK THE GOVERNMENT
HAS ALIENS ON THE ICE AS JUST
CLICKBAIT, BUT IT APPEARS THE
U.S. AIR FORCE IS TAKING THESE
THREATS SERIOUSLY.
JENNIFER GRIFFIN SHOWS ESTIMATE
FROM THE PENTAGON.
>> IT WAS A JOKE, BUT WHEN THE
AIR FORCE IS TAKING SERIOUSLY, A
FACEBOOK POST AND ABOUT FAKE
DESIGNED TO GET LICENSED TO AND
READ THE AIR FORCE BASE IN ABOUT
AN HONEST AREA 51, WHICH HAS
BEEN AT THE CENTER OF UFO AND
ALIEN CONSPIRACY THEORIES FOR
DECADES.
MORE THAN 1 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE
SIGNED UP FOR THE "STORM AREA
51, THEY CAN'T STOP ALL OF US"
EVENT WAITED FOR LATE SEPTEMBER
IN WHICH THE POST ECLAIRS "WE
CAN MOVE FASTER THAN OUR
BULLETS, LET'S SEE THEM ALIENS."
IT'S BEEN ENOUGH TO SPOOK THE
AIR FORCE.
WHICH DOESN'T USE THE TERM AREA
51 TO DESCRIBE THE 2.9 -- THE
LARGEST IN UNITED STATES LOCATED
AT NELLIS AIR FORCE BASE IN
NEVADA.
ONE OF THE MANY REASONS
AIR FORCE OFFICIALS DON'T WANT
PEOPLE TO TRESPASS ON THE BASE,
THEY ARE WORRIED SOME MIGHT BE
KILLED.
"ANY ATTEMPT TO ILLEGALLY
ACCESSED MILITARY INSTALLATIONS
OR MILITARY TRAINING AREAS IS
DANGEROUS."
THERE HAS BEEN RENEWED INTEREST
IN UFO SIGHTING SINCE IT WAS
REVEALED EARLIER THIS YEAR THE
MILITARY HAS SPENT $22 MILLION
TO RESEARCH UFOs AND ANNOUNCED
NEW CLASSIFIED VIOLENCE FOR HOW
ITS PILOTS SHOULD REPORT THEM.
LAST MONTH THE NAVY BRIEFED
SEVERAL SENATORS ON CAPITOL HILL
ABOUT UFO ENCOUNTERS LIKE THIS
ONE.
FROM A NAVY TEAM TRAINING
MISSION FOR YOUR SIGNAL OFF THE
EAST COAST OF THE UNITED STATES
AN UNIDENTIFIED AERIAL
PHENOMENON.
>> YOU HAVE OBJECTS THAT ARE
DOING THINGS, MANEUVERING IN
WAYS WITHOUT ANY OBVIOUS SIGN OF
PROPULSION.
>> IT'S NOT CLEAR THE
1.1 MILLION FACEBOOK FOLLOWERS